in more ways than one Lisa Marie Presley
left a lasting impact on her friends
family and colleagues working on the
film Elvis now the star of that biotech
is paying tribute keep watching to find
out what actor Austin Butler had to say
on January 12 2023 the music world was
stunned by the news that Lisa Marie
Presley the daughter of Priscilla and
the late Elvis had died at the age of
54. the devastating news arrived shortly
after word got held that she'd been
hospitalized due to a medical emergency
the Presley family said in a statement
to CNN following Lisa Marie's death
Priscilla Presley and the Presley family
are shocked and devastated by the tragic
death of their beloved Lisa Marie they
are profoundly grateful for the support
love and prayers of everyone and ask for
privacy during this very difficult time
though an accomplished singer and
songwriter in her own right Lisa Marie
Presley recently found herself in the
news cycle for a very different reason
courtesy of director baz lemon the story
of her father Elvis was brought to the
Silver Screen in the appropriately
titled 2022 biopic Elvis throughout the
film's production the Presley family was
consulted to ensure that Elvis's story
was brought to life in an honorable
fashion and that the actor responsible
for bringing the king of rock and roll
to the cinema Austin Butler did so in
both a mostly accurate and respectful
manner during his work on Elvis Butler
grew Incredibly Close with the Presleys
hence why he delivered a heartfelt
emotional statement on Lisa Marie
Presley's death a day after news of Lisa
Marie Presley's death came to light
Austin Butler released a statement to
variety
my heart has completely shattered for
Riley Finley Harper and Priscilla at the
tragic and unexpected loss of Lisa Marie
going on to Express gratitude for the
time he got to spend with her while
working on Elvis he concluded her warmth
her love and her authenticity will
always be remembered just two days
before her death Prezi was able to
witness Butler Grace a Golden Globe
stage and accept the award for best
actor in a drama for portraying her
father in his emotional acceptance
speech Butler Fang devil is daughter and
wife saying I also want to thank our
incredible producers and the Presley
family thank you guys thank you for
opening your hearts your memories your
home to me Lisa Marie Priscilla Presley
I love you forever Lisa Marie shared the
same affection for Butler following the
release of Elvis the Presley member
candeli shared how impactful Butler's
performance was Presley told ABC he puts
everything he had his heart his soul
everything he had into researching
reading watching learning he honored him
in every way possible in an Instagram
post shared prior to the film's release
Presley gushed about her father's biopic
saying the film managed to capture Elvis
both quote accurately and respectfully
as one could imagine Austin Butler
wasn't the only one involved with Elvis
to come forward and pay tribute to Lisa
Marie Presley with director baz luhrmann
and Tom Hanks the actor behind Colonel
Tom Parker doing the same in an
Instagram post lemon shared a photo of
Butler and Lisa Marie with a caption
expressing how great it was to have her
on the Elvis set he wrote I know her
fans everywhere join me in Sharing
prayers of love and support with her
mother Priscilla and her wonderful
daughters Riley Finley and Harper Lisa
Marie we will miss your warmth your
smile your love
Hanks and his wife Rita Wilson also used
Instagram to honor Lisa Marie but they
paid tribute to her as a mother a
musical talent and a creative
collaborator in addition to sending the
best to the entire Presley family Lisa
Marie Presley will indeed be sorely
missed
[Music]